what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the rumor roundup our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week
and under normal circumstances we cover
video games
tv shows all kinds of cool things but if
we're being honest with ourselves
this week there's only one news story
worth talking about
and it's that scarlett johansson has
filed a lawsuit
against disney now why did this happen
well according to the lawsuit as it was
filed in los angeles
a good portion of scarlett johansson's
salary was tied to the box office
performance
of the black widow film it's estimated
and i'm not going to swear by this
number but it's estimated that scarlett
johansson has lost 50 million dollars as
a result of the movie
being released on streaming services and
theaters at the same time
now we'll get into what kevin feige and
all these guys have to say about this
here in a second
but here's the reason why this is such a
big deal before covet 19 there was just
kind of an alliance between hollywood
production studios
and movie theaters that hollywood
studios were making films but of what
use is a film if there's nobody there to
see it
enter movie theaters that provided a
means by which these films could be seen
that were being made by hollywood
studios the kind of agreement that was
essentially struck here over the years
is that the ticket proceeds from these
movie sales would go to the hollywood
film studios
and the theaters themselves would make
money on concessions now all this
changed with covid19 although if we're
being honest with ourselves
this all really started with netflix but
all this changed with covid19 when we
all experienced the covid quarantine
lockdown
of 2020. we couldn't go anywhere and you
had all these hollywood film studios
that had spent hundreds of millions of
dollars on these movies that were
literally just sitting in a vault or on
somebody's desk in an editing room table
and the reality is while releasing it on
a streaming service
would not garner anywhere near as much
money as that would make in a theatrical
release
fifty percent of something is better
than a hundred percent of nothing and we
couldn't go to movie theaters anyway so
they started releasing them on streaming
services
now at the time nobody had any qualms
about this it just made good business
sense
but once the quarantine lockdowns ended
the expectation
is that we would go back to business as
usual we would have movies that were
made by hollywood studios that would be
released in theaters
they would enjoy a theatrical run of
usually between four to six months
depending on the film
and then would be released to some kind
of a streaming service whether it was
owned by that hollywood production
studio
or some other studio that it was
licensed to what disney did here is by
releasing a movie on a streaming service
and a theater at the same time
it basically blackballed movie theaters
and that's why you see the movie theater
associations and all these major
companies coming out and saying
no this can't be allowed to happen
because it will quite literally
kill the industry now there's a lot of
unanswered questions here specifically
when it comes to why people chose to
watch black widow on a streaming service
instead of in the theaters
honestly there's a lot of people who are
traveling now a lot of people are still
afraid to go out due to the delta
variant that's basically going around
right now so
we don't necessarily have a definitive
answer as to why people enjoyed
the streaming service version of black
widow as opposed to the theatrical run
but what we do know is that when black
widow first opened up in theaters it had
a huge weekend
and then it immediately dropped off and
as a lot of you guys know from your own
casual reading
black widow had the single worst
drop-off of
any movie that's ever been released to
theaters from the marvel cinematic
universe
and so this whole idea of disney
throwing black widow on a streaming
service
from the movie theater's perspective
represents a clear and present danger to
the survival
of movie theaters themselves now the
other big thing about this
is that this will determine how it is
that we have actors actresses
and even staff members in hollywood
going forward in terms of how they
signed contracts
with hollywood production studios in
much the same way that in years past
a lot of people signed contracts with
hollywood film studios
based on the net proceeds of the film
and then the books were cooked to make
it look like the movie didn't actually
make any money so they were basically
left hanging with a zero dollar paycheck
robin williams and aladdin the thing
that a lot of people are doing now is
they're coming forward and they're
saying
no like i want to sign a contract based
on the gross theatrical proceeds of the
film
so that they're basically guaranteed to
walk home with a paycheck scarlett
johansson
did that but the lawsuit seems to allege
that the contract was signed between
scarlett johansson
and marvel but disney is the parent
company more so than that
the lawsuit indicates that disney
actually forced marvel to release the
movie
on disney plus now the reason why this
is such a big talking point is because a
lot of actors actresses
and even members of the marvel cinematic
universe are coming out and saying
something specifically
kevin feige who seems to basically side
with scarlett johansson
now this bit of information comes from
hollywood reporter editor matthew
baloney who basically covered the
concerns of kevin feige in a newsletter
that was previously written
and i quote here feige is not a company
man and not prone to corporate showdowns
or shouting matches but i'm told
he's angry and embarrassed he lobbied
disney against the day-and-date plan for
black widow
preferring the big screen exclusivity
and not wanting to upset his talent
and then when the [ __ ] hit the fan the
movie started tanking and johansen's
team threatened litigation
he wanted disney to make this right with
her now the indication here is that
kevin feige again
sides with scarlett johansson that he
seems to look out for his actresses and
his actors and his staff
more so than that kevin feige went on
record in previously saying that having
a movie from the marvel cinematic
universe released in theaters
offers a kind of experience that you
simply just can't get at home
and that's an accurate statement how
different would infinity war and
avengers in-game have been
if you were sitting at home watching it
on your tv versus sitting in the movie
theater
and it's not just the sound system it's
not just the gigantic screen
it's the audience it's the people who
are there you guys remember the
reactions of everybody and in fact i
still go back and watch them now
the scene where captain america lifted
thor's hammer when t'challa returned
these are all moments that you would not
be able to experience in the same way
had you not seen it in theaters
[Applause]
so there is a benefit to seeing not just
mcu movies
but movies as a whole in theaters that
you simply just can't experience
by seeing it at home now in response to
this whole lawsuit
disney did fire back although the
response has more or less been
criticized
by basically everybody so the statement
released by disney in part
reads like this there is no merit
whatsoever to this filing the lawsuit is
especially sad and distressing in its
callous disregard
for the horrific and prolonged global
effects of the covet 19 pandemic
disney has fully complied with ms
johansen's contract
and furthermore the release of black
widow on disney plus with premier access
has significantly enhanced her ability
to earn additional compensation
on top of the 20 million dollars she's
received to date now we don't know
exactly what this means there was some
kind of a secondary contract that was
signed between scarlett johansson and
disney so that she would receive a
portion of the proceeds of black widow
regardless of what platform it was
released on whether it was in theaters
or on disney plus but if that's the case
why would she file a lawsuit in the
first place
the important thing to take away from
all this though is that this lawsuit
regardless of how it turns out
is going to have a massive impact on the
film industry as a whole
there's no real going back from this and
it could potentially set a massive
precedent
that when a movie is released on a
streaming service and it's released in
theaters that now actors and actresses
have bargaining power they have
precedent here that they can go forward
and they can say look we get the
streaming services are the future
we get that there's going to be a time
whereby movies
are released in theaters and in
streaming services if movie theaters
can't find a way to cope with that
that's their problem that's not the
problem of the hollywood film studios
and so if that's the case they now have
the ability to collectively bargain or
to operate individually and to say
we want to make our money based on the
gross proceeds of not just the
theatrical run
but the streaming service as well and so
how this turns out is going to be
anybody's guess and i'm interested i'm
very very very curious here
but regardless that's our episode for
this week again only one real topic
worth talking about
scarlett johansson suing disney but
thank you guys for watching if there's
any news we missed make sure you guys
let us know down in the comment section
and we will catch you all later peace